Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In a previous episode not so long ago, we
burned down a virtual tree.
This was possible through an amazing simulation
paper from 4 years ago, where each leaf has
its own individual mass and area, they burn
individually, transfer heat to their surroundings,
and finally, branches bend, and, look can
eventually even break in this process.
How quickly did this run?
Of course, in real time.
Well, that is quite a paper, so if this was
so good, how does anyone improve that?
Burn down another virtual tree?
No, no, that would be too easy.
You know what, instead, let’s set on fire
an entire virtual forest.
Oh yeah!
Here you see a simulation of a devastating
fire from a lightning strike in Yosemite national
park.
The simulations this time around are typically
sped up a great deal to be able to give us
a better view of how it spreads, so if you
see some flickering, that is the reason for
that.
But wait, is that really that much harder?
Why not just put a bunch of trees next to
each other and start the simulation?
Would that work?
The answer is a resounding no.
Let’s have a look why, and with that, hold
on to your papers because here comes the best
part: it also simulates not only the fire,
but cloud dynamics as well.
Here you see how the wildfire creates lots
of hot, and dark smoke closer to the ground,
and, wait for it…yes!
There we go!
Higher up, the condensation of water creates
this lighter, cloudy region.
Yes, this is key to the simulation, not just
because of the aesthetic effects, but this
wildfire can indeed create a cloud type that
goes by the name flammagenitus.
So, is that good or bad news?
Well, both!
Let’s start with the good news: it often
produces rainfall, which helps putting out
the fire.
Well, that is wonderful news, so then, what
is so bad about it?
Well, flammagenitus clouds may also trigger
a thunderstorm, and thus, create another huge
fire.
That’s bad news number one.
And bad news number two: it also occludes
the fire, thereby making it harder to locate
and extinguish it.
So, got it, add cloud dynamics to the tree
fire simulator, and we are done, right?
No, not even close.
In a forest fire simulation, not just clouds,
everything matters.
For instance, first we need to take into consideration
the wind intensity and direction.
This can mean the difference between a manageable
or a devastating forest fire.
Second, it takes into consideration the density
and moisture intensity of different tree types
- for instance, you see that the darker trees
here are burning down really slowly.
Why is that?
This is because these trees are denser birches
and oak trees.
Third, the distribution of the trees also
matter.
Of course, the more the area is covered by
trees, the more degrees of freedom there are
for the fire to spread.
And, fourth.
Fire can not only spread horizontally from
tree to tree, but vertically too.
Look!
When a small tree catches fire, this can happen.
So, as we established from the previous paper,
one tree catching fire can be simulated in
real time.
What about an entire forest?
Let’s take the simulation with the most
number of trees, my goodness, they simulated
120k trees there.
And the computation time for one simulation
step was…95.
So, 95 what?
95 milliseconds.
Wow!
So this thing runs interactively, which means
that all of these phenomena can be simulated
in close to real time.
With that, we can now model how a fire would
spread in real forests around the world, test
different kinds of fire barriers and their
advantages, and we can even simulate how to
effectively put out the fire.
And don’t forget, we went from simulating
one burning tree to a hundred and twenty thousand
in just one more paper down the line.
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!